hello grammarians i wanted to talk today
about a different kind of irregular
plural so we've been talking about
regular plurals where you take a word
and you add an s so for example the word
dog
becomes dogs you add an s
and that this is the regular plural here
but i've been talking about the
irregular plural the plural the
multiple form of a verb that is not
regular irregular but today i figured
we'd talk about something called the
base plural
which i will illustrate for you using
our friend the sheep now sheep is a very
strange word in that it doesn't matter
whether or not there's more than one of
them the the form of the word always
looks the same whether it's one sheep or
two sheep it's an irregular plural you
don't add an s to this is called a base
plural because the base sheep the thing
that you would normally add this
particle s to
doesn't change whether it's singular
sheep or plural sheep so
oops you know
there was one sheep
on the hill
there's a sentence
what if we put another little baby sheep
on that hill
a little lamb
well now the sentence looks like this
two sheep
on the hill
now the only difference between these
two sentences is that there's one sheep
and two sheep and therefore that means
that the verb changes to a plural
conjugation so there was one sheep there
were two sheep on the hill but
everything else stays exactly the same
one sheep two sheep
this is very strange it's a base plural
so in standard english the form is two
sheep
and not
two sheeps
you see
now there are more words that do behave
this way so let's uh let's go
investigate
so there are a small number of words
that also behave this way the way sheep
does these weird sheep plurals these
base plurals one of them is fish so you
could say the fish are plentiful this
season but you could also say you know
the fish
is
delicious
you could say the bison migrate west or
you could also say the bison
migrates west indicating a single bison
you see
bison can be singular or plural fish can
be singular or plural
as is so frequently the case there is a
special exception regarding
the word fishes which you may have heard
before and fishes is a word that we
would use when we're talking about
individual species
of fish
and fish is the word that we would use
to refer to
individual fish
so let's say your uncle marty is a
prodigious fisherman and he catches uh
he goes fly fishing one weekend he comes
back he has 30 fish marty
caught
30
fish
but let's say on the other hand your
aunt marta is a prodigious
marine biologist and she studies 30
different types of fish she you would
say
marta
studies
30
fishes that doesn't mean that she
studies 30 individual fish that means
she studies 30 types of fish that's the
difference fishes is referring to
species
fish refers to individuals
that's how you'd use them in the plural
so to review
there is this entire class of words
called base plurals
where the word itself the base doesn't
take an s for the plural it's just the
same the singular is the same as the
plural so that gives us words like sheep
fish
and bison
there aren't a ton of english words that
behave this way where the plural is the
same as the singular i just wanted to
make you aware of some of the most
common ones there are also more examples
in the exercises so i just wanted you to
be aware of them you can learn anything
dave it out